welcome back as far as the Cavanaugh
hearings are going there's just so many
so many hours there's so much content
that we can't possibly cover at all but
there was a moment yesterday that got me
really excited and there's some question
about the legitimacy of that moment but
I still want to address it the Cory
Booker who I'm not a fan of if you go to
my channel I have a video called Cory
Booker's trash so obviously I'm not a
fan of them but you know sometimes
people you don't like do good things and
this is what he did take a look at the
video understand what that kind of civil
disobedience is and I understand the
consequences so I am right now before
your before your process is finished I'm
going to release the email about racial
profiling and I understand that that the
penalty comes with potential outs ting
from the Senate and if senator Cornyn
believes that I violate Senate rules I
openly invite and accept the
consequences of my team releasing that
email right now and I'm releasing it to
expose at number one the emails are
being withheld from the public have
nothing to do with national security
okay so you know in a moment when there
seems to be like nothing else that they
can do it makes absolute sense for the
Democrats to break the rules and there's
there really should be no regard for the
rule at this point because Republicans
have demonstrated time and time again
that they're willing to break the rules
so why should the Democrats hold
themselves to any standard when the
Republicans have demonstrated they're
willing to break every standard in order
to get political wins so I mean Cory
Booker who I'm not a fan of I'm a little
more I'm a little bit more of a fan of
his today I'm considering taking that
video down but not before you go watch
it Cory Booker is trash but I digress
here's the interesting thing about this
story watch The Washington Post is
reporting this quote as it turns out the
documents Booker released had already
been cleared by Burke
now Burke is Burke is a former attorney
for President George HW Bush underneath
the Bush administration and this is what
they also said they said quote this is a
quote from Burke he said quote we
cleared the dock
last night shortly after senator Booker
staff asked us to he said we were
surprised to learn about senator
Booker's histrionics this morning
because we had already told him he could
use the documents publicly now possibly
it could be the case it could be it
could be that cory booker is just simply
grandstanding here but the reason i the
reason i pause about the reason I have
Paul's about Cory Booker just
grandstanding is because of the reaction
of the Republicans when he just
mentioned it he simply mentioned it on
the the night previous to this event and
they lost their minds right and then
even after he did it during the time
that Burke wasn't it William Burke said
that they had already cleared the
documents as he was doing this after he
supposedly knew where all of them are
supposedly have known that these
documents were cleared to be released
Republicans continued to lose their mind
take a look at senator Corbin's warning
to to Cory Booker's any Senator officer
or employee of the Senate who shall
disclose the secret or confidential
business or proceedings of the Senate
including the business and proceedings
of the committees subcommittees and
offices of the Senate shall be liable if
a senator to suffer expulsion from the
body and if an officer or employee to
dismissal from the service of the Senate
and a punishment or contempt so I bring
up I would correct the Senators
statement there is no rule there is
clearly a rule that applies analyze and
bring the charges and so to me it gives
me pause when everyone is saying oh he
obviously knew about it and he was just
grandstanding well in the moment that
they were creating conservatives on the
in that committee tried to make it seem
as though he was going to be put out so
it makes sense to me even if Cory Booker
knew he bluffed them he actually he
trolled them if it is the case that Cory
Booker knew that this was going to be
made public and it was fine for him to
do it
and Republicans were still making this
big scene to try to scare him then the
cards were in his hand he just said
bakken's like I already know I already
know this is not gonna cost me anything
but if you want to make a scene I'll
make a scene with you it's you know
people are like oh why would he possibly
do that I mean you obviously have never
bluffed in poker so I don't know maybe
people don't play poker anymore but I
have a feeling that they they know full
well that the Republicans were trying to
make him bat down and try to make him
afraid to share what he knew he had the
authority to share and even if he didn't
have the authority I'm going to make the
case that the Democrats should just
break all the rules but I'm gonna get
back to that in a second here's another
quote from the Washington Post they said
at issue our documents provided to the
committee before the hearings Cavanaugh
must be evaluated by the committee
before his nomination can be sent to the
full Senate for confirmation Booker of
New Jersey took issue with how and when
some of those documents were released
including a set released after having
been vetted by William Burke an attorney
for president george w bush Cavanaugh
served in bush's administration that is
the problem that's one of the number one
problems here is that so many of the
documents that they don't have access to
have been deemed confidential by a
person who's outside of the senatorial
process how is this William Burke a
private attorney allowed to make
decisions that affect the future of this
country outside of being an elected
official or even being on a committee or
our subcommittee or being an aide to one
of those committees he's not a part of
the process yet this this attorney who
served in the underneath President Bush
at the same time as Cavanaugh has had
access to documents and deemed an entire
swath tens of thousands of documents he
has deemed confidential and this is what
Cory Booker was pushing back against and
this is also a Cory Booker was trying to
expose like him or not and I didn't have
a tendency to not like them thus my
video Cory Booker is trash you can go
check it out on my channel like him or
not
he's right here there's absolutely no
way in hell that this guy who is not an
elected official this person who's not
held accountable to elected officials
who is completely outside of this
process should have the ability to
determine what is confidential and what
is not that is the problem and because
of this this has demonstrated it not
only in this instance but there's so
many instances the Republicans have
demonstrated their will willingness to
completely obliterate tradition
completely ignore norms it completely
reject the institutions that they set up
things like the filibuster they're
willing to to do away with that they're
willing to ignore the the nomination of
Merrick garland they're willing to do
anything and everything to win they are
willing to break every rule to win
because of that I'm fully believe that
the Democrats and anyone else getting
elected into power should reject all of
the rules break every single rule do not
play by the games that they have set up
they being Republicans I want to play
one last clip to make this case look at
how Senator Cornyn is trying to make it
seem as though the Democrats are
behaving badly I was disappointed to see
last night that some of our colleagues
are unwilling or unable to conduct
themselves in this hearing with regular
order and uncoordinated the rules of the
Senate contemptuous I know last night
some of our colleagues even tried to
cross-examine though the nominee about
documents but refused to let him even
read them and this is what I called
weaponized decorum they're attempting to
make the Democrats behave and if they
can always make the Democrats be good
boys and girls and not break Senate
tradition then they have the advantage
because they have demonstrated they
don't care what the Democrats think they
will break Senate tradition and they
will break all the rules
they will do everything that they
possibly can to win and that creates
what I talk about all the time on my
show an asymmetrical
cold battle any time you're in an
asymmetrical fight one side has the
advantage because the other side is not
playing on the same level playing field
Republicans don't hold themselves to any
standards Democrats are trying to play
by the rules and honestly this is the
biggest mistake of duh of Barack Obama's
presidency this is where he was the
weakest President Obama tried to hold on
to institutions like bipartisanship he
tried to hold on to institutions like
decorum he tried to hold on to concepts
and and and that that really Republicans
had rejected a long time ago and he
tried to appeal to the better humanity
and Republicans and he learned the hard
ways and subsequently the rest of us
America learned the hard way
that Republicans don't care
Republicans will break every rule
Republicans will spit in your face and
ask you why are you so angry when you
when you confront them that's exactly
what Republicans would do Republicans
would destroy it they will burn down the
entire house and ask you why are you
upset about it when you confront them
that is the asymmetrical political
battle that we are engaged in and if we
continue to play on this a playing field
this imbalance playing field
Republicans will keep winning over and
over and over again and we cannot afford
that and we cannot let that continue to
happen we absolutely have to put people
in power we have to elect Democrats who
do not care we can't we can't play this
game I think part of the problem is is
that we are afraid the body politic on
the on the Left Democrats are afraid of
what happens when Democrats start acting
like Republican I believe that they're
afraid that there would be an escalation
to something like a destabilization of
America in general or a civil war but
the fact of the matter is is that we've
lost then if that's what you're afraid
of if you're afraid of confronting them
because you're afraid of how it
escalates then they win every single
time we cannot be afraid of fighting
them and therefore we cannot be afraid
of breaking every rule that we have to
break to do the right thing because
Republicans have demonstrated that
they're willing to break every single
wool in order to do the wrong thing